Wo ist denn dieser Mute-Button, Max? Nur kurz, weil ich hab den, ist der hier auf Studio, ist der auf der Studio-Link-Homepage-Seite oder wo finde ich den?
Auf der Studio-Link-Seite neben dem Record-Button.
Da ist nix bei mir.
Aber gut.
Ach so, ach, oh, dieses Mikrofon, ich kann drauf droht. Alles klar. So, Entschuldigung, los geht's.
Point-and-click-Adventure-Studio-Linie.
Ja, wie gut auch noch, dass ich noch gesagt hab, ich brauch euch ja nicht erklären, wie ein Mute-Button funktioniert. Nun ja, also ich wünsche uns eine schöne Sendung und los geht's. Der Rasenfunk – Kurzpass. Die 2. Männer-Bundesliga hat inzwischen 26 Spieltage hinter sich gebracht. Und es gibt so einiges zu erzählen. Unter anderem über Paderborn, den KSC und Hannover 96. Und genau das wollen wir jetzt tun. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Hier ist Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 256. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social. Und ich freue mich heute eine Dreierrunde hier zu begrüßen, zum Teil aus alten Veteranen. Zum ersten Mal seit 2014. Und Schlusskonferenz Nummer 8 wieder im Rasenfunk. Was war da los? Kevin Bublitz vom Padercast. Hallo, Kevin. Hat nur 9 Jahre gedauert, aber so ist das manchmal.
Du musst mich ja nur anschreiben.
Ja, ich muss sie... Naja, gut. Also zwischendurch, als ihr noch in der ersten Liga wart, da hat es auch mal Termin nicht deinerseits nicht geklappt. Aber dann, ja, ich gebe es zu. Ansonsten war es ein klares Versäumnis meinerseits. Wie lange gibt es den Padercast schon, habe ich mich gefragt vor der Sendung.
Seit, seit 2015 müsste das sein. Genau, das war nämlich nach dem Abstieg, hat damals Stefan, Stefan Siemann, den kennt, die weiß ich nicht, meine, genau, die Padercast-Legende, diesen Podcast gegründet.
Genau, und jetzt läuft er immer noch inzwischen auch auf Twitch, also padercast.de, da bekommt ihr alle Informationen zum SC Paderborn und alle Informationen zu Spielern, die irgendwann mal auch nur eine Fußspitze in Hannover 96 stutzen hatten und dann irgendwo anders Tore geschossen haben. Die bekommt ihr nur, wenn ihr Ansgar Löcke folgt. Auf Twitter ist er der Ansgar-L, denn er hat einen Spreadsheet, das inzwischen 3000 Zeilen haben muss, wo er alle im Blick hat. Und man bekommt jedes Tor mit, Ansgar, außer wenn Hannover 96 anschießt. Schön, dass du hier bist.
Ja, moin. Schön, dass ich wieder da sein kann. Ja, es ist ein bisschen ausgeartet, das Projekt. Zumal ja jedes Jahr immer mehr den Verein verlassen, als dann irgendwie doch mal in Ruhestand gehen. Von daher wächst es tatsächlich sehr beständig vor sich hin und langsam stößt es so ein bisschen an seine Grenzen. Aber ich bleib dran.
Aber wie schaffst du es denn da, den Überblick zu behalten?
Tatsächlich ist hauptsächlich das Spreadsheet und dann per Flashscore informiert werden, da allen möglichen Verein zu folgen.
Na gut, also man kann dir auf Twitter folgen und dann wissen wir es. Und du weißt, wann du das letzte Mal hier warst im Rasenfunk?
War das die Saisonabschluss zum Abstieg 2019 nach Thomas Doll?
Ja, das müsste es gewesen sein. Also es war 2019 bei Thomas Doll, da zuckt es gerade bei mir schmerzhaft, also es könnte sein.
Auch ihm geht es gut.
Was macht er denn? Du weißt es ja.
Der ist jetzt in Jakarta, er hat jetzt erst eine NDR-Google gekriegt.
Stimmt richtig.
Und dem geht es dir wirklich gut.
Ich erinnere mich. Ich erinnere mich.
Dann kam ja die Doppelspitze schlaut aufs Lomka und alles wurde gut.
Ja, wir werden ja heute auch ausschließlich positiv über Hannover 96 sprechen, weil das so sein soll. Und wie wir über den Karlsruher SC sprechen, das bestimmt alleine Jörn Kreuzer, der sein Debüt hier im Rasenfunk gibt. Elf Jahre lang war er Social Media Manager bei St. Pauli. Eigentlich ist er aber KSC-Fan und hat im Grunde mit einer Nachfrage dafür gesorgt, dass er jetzt hier ist. Er hat nämlich gesagt, Mensch, Max, ich wünsche mir einen KSC-Schwerpunkt. Und ich habe gesagt, ja, cool, kannst du, Donnerstagabend, er konnte. Und jetzt ist er hier. Hallo, Jörn.
Hallo, Max, herzlichen Dank für die Einladung. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich mich freue. Seit unserem ersten Kontakt ist einiges passiert in den Medien und auch Stellungnahme en masse, aber darüber werden wir sicher sprechen. Das Thema wird ja mein Namensvetter sein, mit dem ich übrigens nicht verwandt bin.
Ja, das wird ein Thema sein, Oliver Kreuzer. Du kannst mir noch die Postlerzahl von Karlsruhe durchgeben, dann nennen wir das hier 90210 Beverly Hills oder so. Ähnlich ist es dann für Karlsruhe. Aber schön, dass du hier bist, Jörn.
Ja, ich freue mich.
Und habe ich das richtig gesehen, dass du nicht mehr auf Twitter aktiv bist?
Ich bin tatsächlich nicht mehr auf Twitter aktiv seit September, also schon bevor Elon den Laden übernommen hat.
Na gut, man muss ja auch so seine Prinzipien haben. So agfier hast du seitdem nicht passiert, wenn man ehrlicherweise ist.
Ich bin beruflich noch auf Twitter unterwegs, tatsächlich. Den Hund habe ich auch entdeckt vor zwei Tagen.
Ja, es ist einfach Wahnsinn. Aber gut, Wahnsinn ist auch die 2. Liga. Bevor wir damit loslegen, möchte ich aber noch loslegen, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Wir werden mit dieser Unterstützung auch dieses Jahr eine eigene Reporterin zur Frauen-WM nach Australien schicken. Also bitte unterstützt uns. Rasenfunk.de support.esklapp.de Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht und auch schon kleine Beträge helfen. Also es gibt genügend Leute, die auch 1 Euro oder 2 Euro im Monat überweisen. Das ist ja dann wirklich doch hoffentlich für die meisten leistbar. Dementsprechend bitte tut das. Wenn das alle von euch machen, dann können wir auch die Gästehonorare weiter erhöhen und den Rasenfunk zur Weltherrschaft aufbauen. Und was könnte man sich Schöneres vorstellen? Vielleicht sollte ich das ein bisschen euphorischer sagen. Naja, merke ich mir fürs nächste Mal. Jetzt blicken wir auf die Tabelle. Wir sehen vorne Darmstadt, Heidenheim, den HSV und St. Pauli. Alles langweilig über die haben wir doch zuletzt erst gesprochen. Aber dann kommt schon auf Rang 5 der SC Paderborn. 53 Punkte hat der SCP, damit 7 Punkte Rückstand auf den 3. Platz, 8 Punkte Rückstand auf den 2. Und zwischendurch, Kevin, sah es auch tatsächlich kurz mal so aus, als ob man da noch mal richtig angreifen könnte. Es gab 3 Siege in Folge, 4 zu 1 gegen Düsseldorf, 4 zu 3 in Hannover, 1 zu 0 gegen Lautern, aber danach ein kleiner Leistungsdelle. Unentschieden gegen Kiel, Niederlage gegen St. Pauli, Unentschieden gegen Magdeburg, Niederlage gegen Regensburg und immerhin jetzt ein 3 zu 2 gegen Greuther Fürth. Gibt es noch Aufstiegshoffnungen bei dir?
Naja, also das 3 zu 2 gegen Fürth, muss man ja erstmal betonen, wir haben den Frankenflug geschlagen, besiegt. Also das ist ja der absolute Angstgegner des SCP. Ich glaube, in den letzten zehn Jahren hatten wir einen Sieg. Der war dann allerdings auch gleich der Rekordsieg für uns in der 2. Liga und gleichzeitig auch die Rekordniederlage für die Fürthe. Aber ansonsten haben wir da nichts geholt gegen die, weder zu Hause noch auswärts. Insofern war das schon ein Ausrufzeichen, aber es war ja ganz schön wackelig am Ende. 3.0 geführt bis zur, ich glaube, 78. Minute oder so. Und dann in der 94. quasi lag das 3 zu 3 in der Luft. Naja, insofern haben wir hoffentlich jetzt wieder die Kurve gekriegt. Das ist ein Auf und Ab. Also insgeheim bin ich optimistisch, dass da noch was gehen könnte. Aber ich sag da einfach nichts zu. Ich sag einfach, Platz 4 wäre auch schön.
Das ist eine Lüge, aber okay, die nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal so hin. Aber gibt es denn für dich von außen erkennbare Gründe, warum das so ist, dass es in dieser Saison mal auf und mal abgeht? Also Paderborn war ja auch lange Tabellenführer bis zum, ich glaube, 8. Spieltag und das ist jetzt zum wiederholten Male, dass man so kleinere Leistungsdellen hatte.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage, weil es zwei verschiedene Szenarien gibt. In der Hinrunde war es tatsächlich so, dass wir einen mega Lauf hatten. Wir hatten ja auch mit Abstand die beste Offensive. Also hatten wir bis vor kurzem ja noch, weil wir davon gelebt haben, von der Hinrunde mit dem 7-2 gegen Kiel und Co. Die Delle haben wir, glaube ich, bekommen durch die DFB-Pokalspiele, weil, wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere – ich bin jetzt schon über 40, da hat man manchmal Lücken – wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, hatten wir dann einige englische Wochen. Und das hat die Mannschaft irgendwie nicht gut weggesteckt. Da war die Mannschaft platt, leer. Für uns kam diese lange Winterpause wirklich wie gerufen. Und wir sind ja dann auch furios aus dieser Winterpause gestartet. Mit vier Siegen, einem Unentschieden und so weiter und so fort. Ja, und dann kam wieder eine Leistungszelle, weil sich quasi unsere komplette Offensive innerhalb von einem Spiel oder einer Woche verletzt hatte. Insofern waren alle Torschützen weg. Dann macht es das halt für einen SCP auch schwierig. Das ist dann nicht so einfach wegzustecken, wenn wir 11 Tore plus 7 Tore plus 8 Tore, also an die 20 Tore wegfallen.
Du hast die Offensive schon angesprochen und die vorderen drei. Robert Leiperts 11 Tore, 1 Assist, Marvin Pieringer 8 Tore, 6 Assists und Felix Platter 6 Tore, 3 Assists. Das habe ich natürlich exakt gerade auch schon genau so gesagt. Wir haben jetzt nicht an dieser Stelle hier geschnitten, was ich sonst nie im Rasenfunk mache. Ich habe keinen peinlichen Fehler begangen, deswegen kannst du jetzt auch einfach ohne zu schmunzeln, mir sagen, was sieht man denn, wenn man SCP-Spiele so guckt?
Ja, Spektakel sieht man in der Regel. Vor allem, wenn es gegen Mannschaften geht, die keine Lust haben, sich hier noch einzustellen. Also gegen Regensburg hat man deswegen zum Beispiel kein Spektakel gesehen, sondern wenn es Teams sind, die mitspielen, die Bock haben. Das hast du jetzt gegen Führer tatsächlich auch gesehen, die ja einen hundsmiserablen Start in der Saison hatten, aber du hast jetzt auch gesehen, dass die schon auch gerne nach vorne spielen und so weiter und so fort gegen Kiel. Ja, feilen mir einige Spiele ein. Auch im DFB-Pokal haben wir deswegen ganz gut ausgesehen gegen Bremen und auch gegen den VfB Stuttgart meiner Ansicht nach. Das sind immer Mannschaften, die mitspielen. Das liegt uns seit Jahren schon. Das ist seit Steffen Baumgart eigentlich auch schon der Fall. Man kann mit Spektakel rechnen, es lohnt sich auch oft, oder seit dieser Saison, wieder ins eigene Stadion zu gehen. Letztes Jahr hatten wir Ladehemmungen, haben fast nur auswärts gewonnen. Diese Saison klappt das zu Hause wieder sehr gut. Du hast die Torschützen zusammengezählt. Die Platte kann man da so ein bisschen rausnehmen. Das war alles an den ersten sechs Spieltagen gefühlt. Danach war es bei ihm vorbei, was sehr schade ist.
Aber lass mal kurz beim Spielstil und dann bei denjenigen, die die Tore machen, auch bleiben. Der große Umbruch liegt da jetzt auch schon ein bisschen zurück, eben von Steffen Baumgart zu Lukas Kwasniok. Das war ja die große Frage. Schafft man es eben, diesen Spielstil, für den man auch bekannt war, zu transferieren? Unter Baumgart war es sehr umschleitfokussiert, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Ist das jetzt genauso oder ist es quasi offensiver mit anderen Mitteln?
Ja, teils, teils. Also wir sind schon immer noch eine Mannschaft, die blitzartig umschalten kann. Das war unter Steffen Baumgart natürlich wirklich auf die Spitze getrieben. Da ging das, war das das Hauptstilmittel. Lukas Kwasniok hat es schon geschafft, der Mannschaft so zwei, drei Gesichter zu verpassen. Also auch so ein bisschen sich auf den Gegner einzustellen, zu gucken. Also wir haben zum Beispiel auch die Abwehrreihe umgestellt. Dreierkette und nicht mehr mit Vieren. Das ist zum Beispiel ein Merkmal, was sich komplett geändert hat. Da sind wir taktisch flexibler geworden, würde ich mal sagen. Also oder positiver ausgedrückt, wir haben die nächste Evolutionsstufe erreicht. Das hat Lukas Kwasniok tatsächlich geschafft. Das war ja wirklich, wie du sagst, die große Frage, kann er daran anknüpfen, sowohl mit der Mannschaft, als auch dann natürlich gegenüber den Fans. Von den Sympathiewerten her waren zwei große Baustellen. Ja, die erste Saison, wie gesagt, hat das zu Hause nicht so funktioniert, aber auswärts und jetzt ist die Mannschaft schon noch mal ein Schritt weiter. Deswegen kommt sie auch nach so Krisen ganz gut zurück. Ich glaube, nach gefühlt fünf oder sechs Spielen ohne Sieg vor der Winterpause kommt nicht jede Mannschaft mit fünf Spielen ohne Niederlage aus der Winterpause.
Jetzt hat ja Lukas Kwasniok auch eine KSC-Vergangenheit, Jörn. Ich weiß nicht, wie genau du ihn da im Blick hattest. Er war bei der Jugend. Ich weiß aber noch, im Schlüsselspieler-Podcast hat er mal ein sehr interessantes Interview gegeben. Das hat mir sehr gefallen. Da hatte ich dann auch Kontakt danach mit ihm. Hat dann nicht mit dem Tribüngespräch geklappt. Und das lag wie immer am Max. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Das hätte sich mal gelohnt im Nachhinein. Aber gut, so ist das. Wundert dich das, wenn du jetzt diese Entwicklung siehst bei Paderborn? War das beim KSC noch nicht abzusehen? Oder anders gefragt, warum ist er nicht KSC-Trainer?
Das ist tatsächlich eine sehr gute Frage. Also ich verfolge den Lukas Kwasnjog tatsächlich noch relativ nah, weil es mich doch interessiert. Der war nämlich bei Oliver Kreuzer relativ am Anfang ein Interimstrainer bei ihm für zwei Spiele.
Ach ja, stimmt, das ja auch.
Genau, und dann muss er zurück zur U19, hat seinen DFB-Trainer gemacht und erschieht dann – lasst mich lügen – zum 1. Juli 2018 beim KSC aus. Es wurde Stillschweigen vereinbart über die Modalitäten, es hatte aber davor wohl Verhandlungen mit Erzgebirge Aue gegeben. Inwieweit das kausal zusammenhängt, kann ich jetzt nicht mehr beurteilen nach fünf Jahren. Habe ich jetzt die Berichterstattung nicht mehr so im Kopf, aber auf jeden Fall fanden es damals alle Leute schade, dass der Lukas Kwasniok nicht weitermachen konnte. Aufgrund der Lizenz war das damals so, wenn ich mich nicht erinnern kann, weil danach müsste dann Mirko Slomka gekommen sein. Genau, Thomas Oral war Trainer, als Kreuzer übernommen hat als Sportchef. Dann war Lukas Kwasniok Trainer, kurz dann Mirko Slomka. Diese Saison 2016-2017 ist unvergessen.
Woran hat man denn da kremen?
Vor allem mit diesen Trainertypen, da muss Lukas Kwasniok rausstechen. Die Mannschaft hat total Spaß gemacht in den zwei Spielen. Daran erinnere ich mich dunkel, das war im Dezember. Das waren, glaube ich, zwei Punkte, bin mir aber nicht mehr sicher. Da müsste ich nachgucken.
Der hat sich auch hart gefreut beim Sieg gegen euch. Irgendetwas ist hinter den Kulissen nicht so gelaufen, wie er sich das wahrscheinlich auch vorgestellt hatte. Ich habe ihn selten so jubeln sehen, wie nach dem Sieg gegen KSC.
Ja, aber da blieben Internaß noch intern, offensichtlich vor fünf Jahren.
Und wir wissen, dass zumindest der Mute-Button von Ansgar auf jeden Fall funktioniert. Denn er hat sich zwar zu Möckers Lomka geäußert, aber nicht direkt, als der Name fiel. Da haben wir das Stöhnen oder den Jauchzeichen. Ich weiß nicht, was es war, Ansgar, aber wir haben es nicht gehört.
Ich hatte seinen verzweifeltes Comeback beim KSC auch schon wieder verdrängt.
Also, was vielleicht noch wichtig ist... Wenn ich das noch ergänzen darf, was bei Lukas Kwasniok auch noch besonders ist, dass er ja tatsächlich mit seiner Familie nach Karlsruhe gezogen ist und bis zur U18 beim KSC gespielt hat, auch als Spieler. Dementsprechend ist da eine enge Verbindung bei ihm sicherlich. Und vielleicht auch etwas emotionaler Jubel bei Spielen gegen KSC möglich. Aber den verfolge ich ganz gerne, genauso wie Muslija.
Ach, das ist ja der einende Spieler für die ganze Runde.
Stimmt, ja.
Der hat sich auch besonders gefreut nach seinen Toren gegen Hannover.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Also ich finde es halt spannend, dass er jetzt immer noch, der war ewig bei uns und ist immer noch erst 24. Ja, letzten Winter zu euch gegangen ist und ja, irgendwie direkt eingeschlagen ist. Wir haben den damals ja vom KSC geholt, ich glaube, nach dem Pokalspiel. Ich glaube, das, was wir gewonnen haben, danach, die Saison, gab es irgendwie das Pokalspiel, was wir dann verloren haben. Aber ich glaube, nach dem Gewonnenen haben wir Muslija dann irgendwie für zwei, drei Millionen, für erstaunlich viel Geld für so einen 18-Jährigen ausgegeben. Ja, hat bei uns aber auch über den ewigen Talentstatus irgendwie nie hinaus geschafft. Und dann war letzten Winter dann Feierabend. Aber finde ich wirklich schön, dass das in Paderborn funktioniert.
Da war es auch richtig wohl.
Wenig Ironie drin, als Ansgar das jetzt gerade gesagt hat. Aber bringt uns ja zu einem interessanten Punkt, Kevin, nämlich der Transferpolitik vom SCP. Und da war es ja schon immer so, dass man mit sehr wenigen Ausgaben, vor allem im Vergleich zu manch anderem Verein, dafür sehr viel rausgehutert hat. Also in der letzten Saison unter Quasseniok war man ja siebter, jetzt liegt man aktuell auf Tabellenplatz fünf. Wer macht diese Transferpolitik und was zeichnet sie aus? Warum erkennt man dann, dass Muslia jetzt genau den Sprung macht?
Also wer die genau macht, es wird wahrscheinlich über die Jahre gewechselt haben. Was aber dann, glaube ich, der entscheidende Faktor ist, wenn man nochmal zurückgeht zu den Jahren, wo wir dann aus der ersten Liga, also nach unserem ersten Aufstieg in die erste Liga, beziehungsweise dann dem ersten Abstieg, haben wir Spieler wie Lakhic, Ndeng und Co. geholt. Um irgendwie hatte man damals die Meinung, die Spieler würden einen in der zweiten Liga halten, was ja dann nicht so gelungen ist. Daraus hat man dann gelernt in Form von Markus Krösche, der kurz vor Steffen Baumgart gekommen ist und heutzutage ja vielen in anderen Vereinen bekannt ist. Der kam in den Verein und hat bei seinem Antrittspfickar gesagt, wir müssten in Eze Paderborn zu einem wirtschaftlichen Unternehmen machen, wo es nicht darum geht, welche Spieler der Trainer will, der gerade eben temporär da ist, sondern welche Spieler zum Spielkonzept des Vereins passen. Das heißt, das galt auch für Trainer und für alle weiteren Angestellten. Markus Krösche hat in Paderborn eine Philosophie installiert oder vorgelebt. Das ist vielleicht ein schöneres Wort, ein schönerer Ausdruck. Dass es wirklich eine Philosophie, eine Vereinsphilosophie gibt, die man dann auch stringent lebt und nicht nur, weil der Trainer geht und ein anderer kommt, komplett über den Haufen wirft. Das ist bis heute gelungen. Das heißt, man macht aus wenig viel. Man scoutet Regionalligaspieler oder auch Drittligaspieler, je nachdem, natürlich auch Zweitligaspieler. Möglichst sind die ablösefrei und versucht die dann halt irgendwann gewinnbringend wieder zu verkaufen. Sie zum Beispiel Schonlaut, der zum HSV ging. Sven-Michel zur Union Berlin ist sicherlich das prominenteste Beispiel im letzten Winter. Damit hat man aber natürlich letzte Saison die Rückrunde fast weggeworfen. Das war der Top-Stürmer, ich glaube, auch in Vorlagen ganz gut dabei, das ist aber das Modell und mal gucken, wie sich das jetzt unter Benjamin Weber, ich weiß nicht, ob den jetzt alle mitbekommen haben, unserem neuen sportlichen Geschäftsführer seit dem Winter, wie das sich unter dem weiterentwickelt, weil der möchte das Ganze ja noch ein bisschen nachhaltiger gestalten, in Form, dass Spieler nicht sofort verkauft werden. Das hat diesen Winter auch einen Riegel vorgeschoben, Entschuldigung, ich bin sofort fertig, mit Ron Schallenberg, der ja heftigst angeblich von Werder Bremen und Schalke 04 umworben wurde oder wird, dass der nicht im Winter schon geht. Naja, mal gucken, was im Sommer passiert.
Das wäre jetzt nämlich auch mal eine Frage gewesen, ob denn das der SC Paderborn überhaupt noch tun muss, auf diese Ablöseerträge, also Einnahmen hinzuarbeiten. Steht man nicht eigentlich inzwischen finanziell relativ stabil da? Stadion steht jetzt schon eine ganze Weile und so fort. Man hat ja so viele kleinere Sponsoren, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Ja, man hat tatsächlich ja geschafft, sich in den grünen Bereich zu katapultieren. Das heißt, früher war ja Wilfried Finke oft als Gönner auch bekannt, der ehemalige Präsident des SCP, der mittlerweile verstorben ist und hat den Verein öfter mal finanziell in Anführungsstrichen gerettet oder unter die Arme gegriffen. Das ist inzwischen nicht mehr nötig, notwendig. Da hat der Verein sich gerade durch die beiden Bundesliga-Runs natürlich auch ein bisschen gesundet und aber auch durch diese Transferpolitik nicht wieder ins Minus getrieben. Man hat konsequent eher nicht in Beine, sondern in Steine investiert, das heißt, die Infrastruktur nachgezogen. Wir haben ein Trainingszentrum, was gerade bei Paderkars, Gästen schon ein Running Gag ist, das sich wirklich sehen lassen kann. Das wird auf Dauer auch der Weg sein, dass wir jetzt der nächste Schritt sein, dass wir auch unsere eigenen Jugendspiele hochkriegen.
Also es ist durchaus erstaunlich, der SCP hat die viertwenigsten Verbindlichkeiten aller Männer-Profi-Fußballvereine.
Wir sind super durch die Pandemie gekommen. Das kann man natürlich sagen, weil ihr immer nur zwischen 10.000 und 15.000 Fans da habt, habt ihr es natürlich nicht so bemerkt vielleicht, dass nicht mehr 80.000 da sind. Mal jeder Punkt. Weiß ich nicht, kann sein. Andererseits wirtschaftet man hier tatsächlich auch defensiv. Beim letzten Bundesliga gab es auch viel Kritik aus bestimmten Fanlagern. Dass man jetzt nicht noch Spieler gekauft hat, die einen vielleicht dann schaffen, in der 1. Liga zu halten, sondern man ist ja ganz bewusst unter Steffen Baumgart quasi mit dem Kader, mit dem man aufgestiegen ist in die Bundesliga gegangen und ist dann ja auch am Ende seinem Grund klanglos abgestiegen, was Steffen damals auch nicht wirklich gefallen hat. Aber ja, so ist der Vereinsweg und deswegen, um deine Frage gerade nochmal klar zu beantworten, der SCP braucht momentan trotzdem auf jeden Fall das Geld, weil wenn du mal das Budget vergleichst zu einem Erstligisten, ist die Kluft halt riesig. Zum HSV gesehen weiß ich es nicht und so, dürfte aber auch noch groß sein.
Ja, also wenn man sich allein das Rohergebnis anguckt, das ist ja immer so ein ganz guter Indikator für das Potenzial, das ein Verein hat, weil da steht quasi alles drin, was man sich über Transfer, Sponsoren und so weiter reinholt, dann liegt in den drei Jahren, in denen hier die Daten von der DFL schon vorliegen, das heißt von 2018 bis 2021, da liegt der SCP da immer rund um den 30. 32. 34. Platz eben im Vergleich zu allen anderen. Also sprich, man muss immer überperformen sportlich, um den wirtschaftlichen Rückstand reinzuholen. Und da wird ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal so viel wachsen können, oder? Weil die Region ist ja auch relativ stark besetzt, schon in wenigen Kilometern Entfernung sitzen die nächsten Vereine, das heißt, da kann man ja kaum Fans rüberziehen und auch Sponsoren sind ja nicht unbegrenzt zu finden.
Ja, nach Bielefeld hat sich vielleicht jetzt wirklich langsam rumgesprochen, wo man guten Fußball sehen kann, wobei jetzt nach dem Trainerwechsel haben die jetzt ja auch mal wieder gewonnen und Münster ist ja, also weiß ich nicht. Du meinst natürlich eher so auch BVB und Co. das ist natürlich so ein Ding. Viele hier in der Region sind natürlich Dortmund, Schalke-Fans, Bündchen Gladbach sogar, also klar hast du viele alteingesessene Bundesligisten, die dir so, die dich für viele zum Zweitverein machen, wobei das ja auch unsäglich ist.
Und dann fährt auch noch die S-Bahn bis nach Hannover.
Das ist tatsächlich das S-Bahn-Duell, ne?
Also wenn ihr dann irgendwann bei höheren Weinen ein größeres Stadion braucht, ich glaube, wir vermieten immer günstig.
Wir können ja tatsächlich unser richtig noble Arena, die ja von manchen einem verspottet wird, können wir ja wie ein Baukastensystem quasi beliebig ausbauen. Insofern wird sie ja jetzt auch, nur es werden halt nicht mehr Plätze drinnen stattfinden. Also es wird halt einfach ein bisschen geräumiger. Und es wird sehr schick aussehen.
Entschuldigung, wie? Also wie wandelst du jetzt den Sitzplätze oben? Macht ihr tatsächlich?
Es kommt ein Oberrang, ja, tatsächlich. Wir kriegen jetzt das Sitz bald aus wie in Leverkusen.
Aber Moment mal, warum wandelt man? Also weil man das Geld braucht? Oder normalerweise ist ja eigentlich das, was man haben möchte, Stieplätze. Zumindest wenn man Stimmung haben will und wenn man erschwindliche Ticketspreise und so weiter haben will. Also warum wird das gemacht?
Naja, wahrscheinlich, um die Einnahmen zu erhöhen. Und ich weiß nicht, wie die Vorgaben der DFL sind, wie viel Sitzplätze man braucht mindestens. Da habe ich keine, ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich das nicht. Also ursprünglich war der Plan ja, die Kapazität auch zu erhöhen. Also ich glaube von 15 auf 17, 5 oder 18.000. Das wird man aber denke ich nicht machen, solange man in der 2. Liga spielt. Also das wäre nur ein Schritt, wenn man irgendwann utopischerweise ein paar Jahre sich weiter oben hält. Auf jeden Fall kriegen wir auch eine farbenfrohe LED-Anlage. Das heißt, unsere Arena wird man demnächst auch in verschiedenen Farben anstrahlen können, so wie die in München.
Das ist krass, Kevin. Ich wünsche dir damit ganz viel Spaß mit diesen Lichtshows. Da versammeln sich hier immer alle Münchner und staunen in Richtung Klärdach, wenn es da wieder bunt leuchtet. Aber ist das ein nächster Schritt, der jetzt durchaus mal kommen muss, dass der SCP auch mal wieder aufsteigt? Oder das wäre jetzt mal eine abschließende Frage für dich. Also, dass man aufsteigen will, ist ja klar. Aber wo sieht sich der SCP jetzt mal so auf die nächsten fünf Jahre hingesehen? Muss da auch mal ein Aufstieg bei rumkommen?
So wie man wirtschaftet nicht, weil man schafft es ja tatsächlich in der 2. Liga im positiven Bereich immer zu enden im Geschäftsjahr. Natürlich haben gewisse Fans da Lust zu und gerade die jüngeren Fans lechzen dann natürlich dann nach, also die nachrückenden Fans, sage ich mal. Ich kenne auch viele, die sagen, das sei ganz schön in der 2. Liga. Da spielen wir auch immer eine gute Rolle, da können wir unsere Talente entwickeln, einen super offensiven Fußball spielen, wo wir dann auch gewinnen. In der Musiker haben wir den ja auch gespielt beim letzten Mal, haben aber leider oft verloren. Insofern, ja, also bis Benjamin Weber im Winter kam, hat man gesagt, man muss nicht aufsteigen, der möchte aber ganz gerne, glaube ich. Und Lukas Kwasniok kennt sowieso. Der ist sonst, also der hat sich zwar hier dem SCP verschrieben und liebt es auch hier zu sein, das glaube ich ihm sogar auch, aber wenn das nicht irgendwann hochgeht, dann ist das halt dann auch wie zum Beispiel in Karlsruhe oder wie in Saarbrücken, wo er dann nach diesem phänomenalen DFB-Pokal-Run auch gesagt hat, so bis hier und nicht weiter, ich entwickle mich ein bisschen schneller, als der Fein sich mitentwickeln kann und dann war er weg.
Dann war er weg, aber bisher ist ja der SCP bewundernswert durch alle Personalfluktuationen durchgekommen und wie gesagt, 7 Punkte sind es auf Rang 3. Wir werden gucken, was da geht und wir wollten uns jetzt mit dem KSC beschäftigen, was gut ist, denn den Tab habe ich schon offen. Das wissen alle drei Gäste, denn ich habe vorhin einfach die KSC-Stürmer vorgelesen anstelle der SCP-Stürmer und wann ist es mir aufgefallen? Gar nicht. Ich bin einfach…
Das hast du ja doch verraten.
Ja, weil es ist ja albern, wenn ich hier schneide. Eigentlich schneide ich nie in Rasfunk, deswegen schäme ich mich jetzt dafür, dass das ist, aber ja, meine Güte. Also so gut kenne ich mich in der 2. Liga aus, ist einfach ganz fantastisch, aber ich weiß immerhin, Jörn, dass beim KSC sowieso gerade nicht das Sportliche zählt. Das heißt, ich hatte ja gar keine Chance, die Stürmer-Namen zu kennen, denn es geht ja nur um Oliver Kreuzer und um Stilfragen. Und das kenne ich hier aus München gar nicht, deswegen musst du mir mal erklären, was war denn da los?
Ich glaube, es geht nicht nur um Stilfragen am Ende des Tages. Ich hatte dir ja schon im Vorgespräch gesagt, ich kann euch jetzt, glaube ich, einen ganz schönen Cocktail präsentieren, wenn man das so sagen kann. Also man mixt ein bisschen Frankfurt, Stress im Gremium mit Bayern München, Entlassung per E-Mail gewissermaßen und nimmt dann irgendwie noch St. Pauli aus dem Dezember dazu. Was die Begründung angeht, so in der offiziellen PM, dann kommt man im Wildpark Stadion raus. Und ich versuche das, also Karlsruherinnen und Karlsruher, die zuhören, falls ihr noch Ergänzungen habt, ergänzt das gerne per persönlicher Nachricht dann bei Rasenfunk. Ich versuche das jetzt mal zu ordnen. Es ging am Samstag, also für die Öffentlichkeit jetzt erstmal, ich glaube, man muss es ordnen, in den Zeitpunkt wann, über die Stilfrage wie und dann vor allem warum auch. Es ging Samstag los, da gab es nach dem 1 zu 1 gegen Braunschweig plötzlich Gerüchte in der Presse, dass der Karlsruher SC den Oliver Kreuzer als Geschäftsführer Sport abberufen würde bzw. entlassen würde. Das Thema wurde dann ganz heiß und dann gab es plötzlich auf der Homepage noch eine Pressemitteilung, die dann über die sozialen Medien rausgeschickt wurde und wo dann der Verein auch schnell drunterschrieb. Leute, es ist leider kein April-Scherz. Also leider haben sie sich gespart, aber es ist kein April-Scherz. Und in der Pressemitteilung steht, der Aufmacher ist tatsächlich die Fertigstellung des Wildparkstadions, auf die wir uns sehr freuen, dass da quasi ein Weiterentwicklungsprozess jetzt beginnt. Und man habe noch mal analysiert und festgestellt, dass im Handlungsfeld Sport einfach zu wenig Geld generiert wird, also TV-Gelder und Transfererlöse. Und dementsprechend wolle man sich strategisch neu ausrichten und Oliver Kreuzer als Geschäftsführer abberufen. Und in dem weiteren Absatz steht dann eben noch, dass da zusätzlich auch noch sportliche Ziele erreicht werden sollen. Diese Meldung ging Oliver Kreuzer offensichtlich, das hat dann auch der KSC öffentlich so eingestanden per E-Mail zu. Hintergrund war der, dass man versucht hat, ein Gespräch nach dem Spiel gegen Braunspeig zu führen. Oliver Kreuzer sei aber nicht greifbar gewesen, beziehungsweise nicht rechtzeitig greifbar, weil der Aufsichtsrat quasi noch mit der Geschichte befasst war, ob das alles so korrekt ablief. Und dann hat der Beiratsvorsitzende Holger Sigmund Schulze versucht, Oliver Kreuzer, der in Richtung Niederland unterwegs war, zum Scouten, versucht, telefonisch zu erreichen. Und weil er das nicht erreicht hat, hat er dann persönlich gesagt, hat er sich für die zweitschlechteste Variante entschieden, bevor er es über die Medien erfährt. Das Thema wurde durchgestochen, zumindest per persönlicher Mail. Vielleicht noch zum Hintergrund, am Freitag, das kam jetzt über die letzten Tage raus, weil der KSC sehr unter Rechtfertigungsdruck kam, so gesehen, bzw. vor allem der Beirat. Der Beirat ist beim KSC strukturell ein Gremium, das aus dem Präsidium besteht, quasi Präsident und die zwei Vizepräsidenten und eben noch zwei weiteren Beiräten, die von der Mitgliederversammlung gewählt werden. Also ein fünfköpfiges Gremium, das am Freitag über die Abberufung von Oliver Kreuzer entschieden hat und die Abstimmung, das wissen wir auch, ging 3 zu 2 aus gegen Kreuzer.
Also es war quasi ein schlechter Ablauf, für den sich der KSC ja auch im Nachhinein entschuldigt hat und es war eine enge Entscheidung und ich glaube dazu muss man nochmal sagen, ich meine so grob haben wir das alle im Kopf, dass Oliver Kreuzer eine wichtige Rolle beim KSC gespielt hat. Aber nochmal kurz, um das zu verdeutlichen, er hat 182 Spiele für den KSC gemacht und er war ja schon zweimal dann auch in sportlich führenden Funktionen tätig und jetzt eben tatsächlich seit 2016, wenn ich mir das richtig gemerkt habe. Also es ist hier keine einfache Personalie, das war jetzt nicht irgendwie der Stellvertreter des Zeugwarts, der da per Mail gekündigt wurde.
Genau, er war von 85 bis 91 Spieler beim KSC, ich habe noch rausgesucht aus der Karlsruher Presse, er war tatsächlich über 3000 Tage Sportchef, so lange wie kein anderer in der Geschichte des Karlsruher Sportklubs. Also sprich, es ist aus meiner Perspektive eine enorm wichtige Personalie, bzw. eine wichtige Person. Und ja, was man vielleicht auch noch zu dem Beirat sagen muss, was spannend ist bzw. bemerkenswert bei dem ganzen Vorgang ist, dass Holger Sigmund Schulze als Präsident des KSC für die Abberufung gestimmt hat und die zwei beisitzenden Beiräte, also Christian Fischer und Thomas Hock, und tatsächlich die Vizepräsidenten dagegen gestimmt haben. Und das kam eben auch in der Öffentlichkeit raus, weil sich die Vizepräsidenten über die Abstimmung bzw. über das Ergebnis beschwert haben. Und ich glaube, da muss man jetzt öffentlich gar nicht so drüber spekulieren, wer jetzt was gesagt hat. Ich glaube, allein die Tatsache, dass die beiden sich beschweren, deutet schon darauf hin, dass in dem Gremium aktuell nicht alles rund läuft. Und ich finde tatsächlich auch, der KSC hat den Hinweis gegeben, dass die Abstimmung demokratisch war. 3 zu 2 ist demokratisch, ist legitim, akzeptiere ich jetzt als Mitglied, sage ich mal, auch. Aber in so einer wichtigen Frage finde ich 3 zu 2 schon, wie soll man sagen, nicht so richtig eindeutig. Und das lässt jetzt für die Zukunft, für die nähere Zukunft in Beirat, nicht so viel Positives hoffen, wenn da fünf Egos aufeinanderprallen, sage ich mal. Also das hatten wir ja öfter auch schon im Fußball. Was kann man noch?
Ja, das eine ist ja dann die politische Ebene. Dann lass doch aber mal gucken zu dem Sportlichen, um das es ja eigentlich geht, wo ja eben auch jetzt gesagt wird, Mensch, ist ja schön, dass das Stadion jetzt fertig ist. Die coolen Sachen dann, wenn wir das Stadion haben, die wollen wir lieber ohne dich machen, weil wir wollen uns eben weiterentwickeln. Wie viel kann man denn, Oliver, oder muss man Oliver Kreuzer vorwerfen, wenn man auf die letzten Jahre blickt und jetzt eben mal dieses politische und mögliche Animositäten und so weiter versucht, da rauszuhalten?
Das ist tatsächlich sehr schwierig. Ich glaube generell haben Sportchefs manchmal nicht so einen leichten Stand, weil du machst Kaderplanung, stellst dir einen Kader zusammen und der funktioniert plötzlich einfach und quasi dieselbe Planung, die du dir im Kopf hinterlegt hast, rein von der Struktur, funktioniert dann im nächsten Jahr eben nicht. Ich habe mir tatsächlich auch eine Liste gemacht in Vorbereitung der Sendung, was man so aufzählen könnte. Also, es geht ja in der Abberufungsmitteilung, geht es ja auch um sportliche Ziele. Die sportlichen Ziele, die Oliver Kreuzer vorgegeben bekommen hat, war Konsolidierung und Klassenerhalt. Das hat er seit dem Wiederaufstieg jedes Mal geschafft. Was er jetzt auch in der konkreten Planungsphase zur neuen Saison – deshalb war ja auch der Zeitpunkt so kritisch, weil er mitten in der Planungsphase zur neuen Saison ist. Es laufen 14 Verträge aus.
Angeblich musste er erstmal Lars Stündl anrufen, der heiß gehandelt wird.
Genau, das hat jetzt Christian Eichner laut Pressemeldungen übernommen. Was er tatsächlich geschafft hat, ist, er konnte jetzt zumindest in der Transferphase einen Stamm an Spielern schon mal binden, die für uns sehr wichtig sind. Unter anderem eben Marvin Warnizek und Schleusner. Da wurden die Verträge verlängert. Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist, dass er immer Spieler geholt hat, die für eine hohe Identifikation mit dem Verein stehen können. Also beispielsweise Marius Gersbeck hat sich auch unter Kreuzer vom Ersatzmann von Upov, der dann nach Freiburg gewechselt ist, zum Stammkeeper, zu einem sehr guten Stammkeeper, entwickelt. Marius Gersbeck ist quasi Herthaener durch und durch. Es gibt eine Fan-Freundschaft zwischen Karlsruhe und Hertha. Gersbeck stand schon mal in der Gegend gerade, im Wildpark. Das passt alles. Jérôme Gondorff ist Karlsruher, kommt aus Karlsruhe. Warnizek ist, wenn er den Vertrag erfüllt, zehn Jahre da, kommt auch aus der Gegend. Also das finde ich durchaus positive Aspekte, die auch sehr wichtig sind in der Kaderzusammenstellung. Und er hat es geschafft, Leute wie Sebastian Jung beispielsweise oder Philipp Heise in den Wildpark zu lotsen. Das ist die eine Seite. Beispiele Jung und Heise kann man jetzt quasi die Gegenseite argumentativ so ein bisschen verwursten, sage ich mal. Da oftmals wird gesagt, diese Spieler sind zu alt. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Oliver Kreuzer auch Erfahrungen ausgemacht hat, als einen wichtigen Punkt, wenn man in der 2. Liga bestehen will, unten drin und den Klassenerhalt schaffen will. Dementsprechend kann ich das grundsätzlich nachvollziehen, aber ich kann auch nachvollziehen, dass man sagt, diese Spieler sind zu alt. Ein Argument, das ich immer kritisch gesehen habe, persönlich ist tatsächlich, dass er es nicht geschafft hat, im Schatten der Aufstiegsmannschaft Leute zu holen, die zu Stammspielern heranreifen. Also, man hat irgendwie 2020, hat man nach dem Wiederaufstieg am letzten Spieltag im Viertz spektakulär den Klassenerhalt geschafft und man hat im Endeffekt in der nächsten Saison mit derselben Mannschaft gespielt, weil uns eben auch die Kombination Vanicek auf Philipp Hoffmann oftmals auch durchgetragen hat. Also, wenn gar nichts mehr ging, konnte man sich möglicherweise auf eine Ecke oder auf einen Freistoß von Banne verlassen, der auf Hoffis Kopf gelandet ist. Aber da sehe ich halt tatsächlich in den letzten zwei Jahren keinen Spieler, den man so im Schatten so ein bisschen rangezogen hat zum Stammspieler. Und das wird jetzt langsam problematisch, weil tatsächlich die Leistungsträger der Aufstiegsmannschaft werden langsam alt. Ich glaube, die Außenverteidiger sind beide über 30 bzw. jenseits der 30. Und da ist weit und breit kein Ersatz zu sehen. Genauso im defensiven Mittelfeld, da hatten wir jetzt quasi das Glück, dass mit Tim Breithaupt wieder ein tolles Eigengewächs hochkam. Aber wir haben nicht so richtig Ersatz für Jérôme Gondorf beispielsweise, der das dauerhaft spielen kann. Letzte Saison hat es zum Beispiel beim Spiel auf St. Pauli, haben das dann Außenspieler gemacht, die zentrale Position, weil Gondorf gesperrt war und die Mannschaft noch wegen dem Pokalspiel gegen HSV in der Stadt war. Da gab es dann so spannende Konstellationen. Und tatsächlich, das muss man auch sehen, das ist ja auch ein Argument für seine Abberufung gewesen, dass es keine Spieler zuletzt gab, die Werte erzeugt haben. Zum Beispiel, ein prominentes Beispiel war Philipp Maxx. Das ist so einer, der mir einfällt. Der war eine Saison da, hat spektakulär gespielt und wechselte dann. Und ich glaube, solche Spieler stellen sich die Entscheidungsträger vor. Und jetzt kommen wir zu großen Krux. In der Situation, in der der KSC seit einigen Jahren ist, finde ich es extrem schwierig, sportlichen Erfolg quasi und Kader-Weiterentwicklung zueinander zu bringen. Weil wenn Spieler gut sind, fallen sie auf, sind direkt weg und man muss wieder aufbauen. Und das finde ich halt schon so eine strukturelle Geschichte, die man Oliver Kreuzer am Ende nicht vorwerfen kann, weil er am Ende das erfüllt hat, was man ihm vorgegeben hat grundsätzlich.
Ja, aber das ist interessant, weil wir hier nämlich wirklich ganz gut zu Paderborn vergleichen können. Wenn man sich nämlich die Finanzkennzahlen anguckt, dann sieht man, es ist ungefähr eine Liga. Rohergebnis, ich habe es auch vorhin gesagt, bei Paderborn waren wir auf Rang 34, KSC 32. Und so rund, man hat ein bisschen mehr Schulden und der Personalaufwand ist aber auch ungefähr vergleichbar. Und dann gucke ich mir einmal die Transferseiten an und habe das mal genau für die Zeit, in der eben Oliver Kreuzer auch zuständig war. Also ab der Saison 16, 17 habe ich das einberechnet. Und dann sehen wir bei den Ausgaben, Paderborn hat 2, 7 Millionen Euro investiert, der KSC hat 3, 0 irgendwas, also alles jetzt laut Transfermarkt.de investiert, aber die Transfererlöse, die unterscheiden sich krass. Der KSC hat 5 Millionen eingenommen, also insgesamt ein positives Seito von 2 Millionen und der SDP Paderborn aber 15, 5 Millionen, also 12 Millionen, damit sogar ein bisschen mehr, also aufgrundet sogar 13 Millionen damit erlöst. Das scheint ja doch ein großer Unterschied zu sein, das heißt Kevin müsste doch eigentlich jetzt erklären, woran Herr Hagts hätte man auch Markus Krösche irgendwann mal durch den Verein durchlaufen lassen müssen.
Wahrscheinlich, für mich tatsächlich sogar sehr wahrscheinlich, dass das dann richtig gut gewesen wäre. Der ist nämlich nicht umsonst bei diesen ganzen Vereinen da jetzt angekommen und wird in England gehandelt. Woran Hagts, das ist immer so schwer zu beurteilen, ich kenne den KSC viel zu wenig dafür. Ich kann ja nur sagen, was wir haben und ich weiß nicht, ob der KSC das auch hat. Also modernes Trainingszentrum, eine Wohlfühlmentalität, also familiär, wenn ich das vorhin gehört habe, dass per E-Mail Schluss gemacht wird mit einem langjährigen, verdienten Spieler und sportlichen Leiter. Da ist bei uns das letzte Mal sowas Ähnliches, kurioses mit Stefan Effenberg passiert, wenn sich da noch dran erinnert. Also wir haben in den letzten Jahren viel, viel positive Mentalität rausgehauen und das macht wirklich viel, viel aus. Die richtigen Leute, um die Mannschaft herum auch zu haben, im Aufsichtsrat, im Vorstand und was für Gremien es noch alles gibt.
Aber bei den Gremien, da wissen wir ja schon, dass es beim KSC jetzt ein bisschen anders läuft. Aber wie ist es denn bei den anderen Sachen, die jetzt Kevin genannt hat, Jörn? Also Infrastruktur eben zum Beispiel und auch generell das Umfeld, vielleicht auch medial gesehen.
Naja, im Endeffekt ist die Infrastruktur vorhanden und das schon immer. Also man hat quasi den Platz 2 direkt am Stadion, man hat 3 oder 4 Trainingsplätze, man hat da eine Turnhalle zur Verfügung, das NLZ ist hoch anerkannt. Es kommen immer wieder Jugendspieler nach und das, obwohl die Konkurrenz extrem groß ist in der Gegend mit dem SC Freiburg, mit Hoffenheim und mit Stuttgart mindestens. Also daran liegt es nicht und quasi die größte Baustelle wird ja, also im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, wird ja jetzt quasi geschlossen, also mit dem Wildpark-Stadion, das jetzt auch neu ist. Also daran kann es sich liegen und mediales Umfeld hattest du gefragt, Max, das ist ja auch jetzt in den turbulenten Tagen, die ich jetzt vor allem turbulent wahrgenommen habe offensichtlich, weil medial kann man eigentlich relativ gut arbeiten und ruhig. Beispiel, die Größe Boulevard-Zeitung hat vor Ort gar keinen Reporter. Also dazu hat man zumindest gestern noch nichts gefunden über die ganze Kausa-Kreuzer.
Hier auch nicht.
In Hamburg wäre das ein Fest, beispielsweise. Ja, also von daher, es sind eigentlich alle Dinge vorhanden und man merkt halt auch so, der beschauliche Partner, der beschauliche Partnerin, man hat es jetzt auch in den letzten Tagen gemerkt, es ist schon irgendwie unangenehm, wie sich der Beirat verhalten hat. Also damit meine ich jetzt nicht das Abstimmungsergebnis, sondern vor allem aus Sicht der aktiven Fans haben da vor allem die Vizepräsidenten Gegenwind bekommen, die ja quasi auch noch nach der Abstimmung öffentlich mit ihrem Geld gewedelt haben, so macht der Motto. Ihr wolltet ein Parkhaus, wir solltet ein Parkhaus bauen mit unserem Geld, das gibt es jetzt erstmal nicht. So, das ist ja auch so.
Also es gibt jetzt dieses Parkhaus wirklich nicht.
Also ja, die Pläne liegen erstmal auf Eis, das haben die Vizepräsidenten Müller und Pulaski gesagt.
Und die hätten das quasi so aus Medizinatentum finanziert, oder?
Ja, die hätten das finanziert und aber der Präsident, wie gesagt, ich will jetzt so in diese Schlammschacht nicht zugehen.
Das ist ja Weltklasse. Ja, dann geht ihr doch dahin. Dann spielen wir eben. Aber dann eben nicht hier. Das ist mit 7 Euro in der Südkurve einfach nicht zu finanzieren.
Ja, und ich, vielleicht quasi, um nochmal, bevor wir die Kurve zurückbekommen und das vielleicht nochmal abzuschließen. Also ja, also die haben quasi damit und jetzt hat quasi der Präsident, also der Beiratsvorsitzende, hat dann auch gesagt, das Parkhaus ist doch schon vor einigen Wochen gestorben, so nach dem Motto. Aber wie gesagt, diese Schlammschacht müssen wir vielleicht nicht so ganz ausbreiten an der Stelle, weil quasi die sich nur in Stellung bringen wollen jeweils. Aber der, der, quasi der Dachverband der KSC-Fans, die Supporters, die waren dann quasi auch am Mittwoch in der Stellungnahme gestern auch quasi um das Schließen der Reihen gewissermaßen irgendwie bemüht. Die haben gesagt, über den Stil muss man nicht reden, rein von der Geschäftsordnung und vom Ablauf war das ein demokratischer Prozess, den man halt akzeptieren muss. Und da haben sie halt auch ganz klar gesagt, vielleicht sollte jetzt endlich mal der Beirat wieder hinter verschlossenen Türen arbeiten und quasi professionell. Also das ist so, das war der Versuch, die Reihen zu ordnen, weil wie gesagt, wir müssen weitermachen. Es sind Verträge zu verlängern oder auch nicht. So, das kann ich total nachvollziehen. Und wir sind ja noch nicht ganz über der Ziellinie mit 35 Punkten. Aber wer dann gedacht hat, dass es das war, der wurde jetzt quasi in den letzten zwei Tagen nochmal überrascht. Denn es gibt ein KSC-Mitglied, das wohl trommelt, um die 300 Mitglieder zusammen zu bekommen für eine außerordentliche Mitgliederversammlung, wo sich eben die 3 Leute, die für die Abberufung von Oliver Kreuzer gestimmt haben, ein Misstrauensvotum stellen sollen. Ob das jetzt am Ende zustande kommt, werden wir sehen. Aber der KSC hat turbulente Wochen vor sich, auch vor dem Hintergrund der Kaderplanung. Und ich bin total, wie gesagt, ich habe mich jetzt die letzten fünf Tage, habe ich mich, glaube ich, durch 50 Artikel durchgearbeitet. Es war krass, aber es war auch irgendwie fantastisch, weil ich nochmal den KSC nochmal etwas intensiver kennengelernt habe, in dem Punkt.
Das sind fast 96er-Zustände. Bei Hannover war es auch mal so, dass ich quasi gerade eine Woche später die Leute schon geschrieben habe, als kann es schon die nächste mal wieder so viel passieren.
Also ich finde die Aussage im Gremium, was 3 zu 2 beschließt, ist uns demokratisch zu knapp, finde ich ja fast schon putzig, weil bei Hannover wird einfach bei einem 2 zu 2 Gremium gesagt, dass es wird abberufen. Wir können das noch ganz anders.
Das war ja gewissermaßen meine Wahrnehmung. Also so wie ich Fußballgremien kennengelernt habe, war das eigentlich nur so beschreiben, dass ich mir denke, wenn es 3 zu 2 steht, das kann eigentlich nicht gut ausgehen in den nächsten Monaten. Also das war eher so gemeint.
Genau. Aber andererseits, wenn euch jetzt ein Geschäftsführersport fehlt, bei uns ist ja der Schwager von Christian Eichner als Geschäftsführer, der frisch verlängert hat. Also der wird sich jetzt das vermutlich aber auch nicht antun, trotz familierer Beziehung.
Darf ich dir was verraten? Der Michael Mutzel, der im Gespräch ist, ist der Trauzeuge von Christian Eichner.
Meine Güte!
Eine Bagage da unten.
Hallo, hallo.
Ich dachte immer, der FC Bayern hätte den KSC einfach irgendwann mal leer gekauft und dann ging es halt dahin. Aber ich wusste gar nicht, wie viel der KSC auch vom FC Bayern übernommen hat. Das ist ja wirklich…
Ja, aber im Endeffekt…
Was heißt übernommen? Das ist wahrscheinlich alles von Kahn, damals noch. Das ist von 30 Jahre her.
Vielleicht könnte er auch seine Handelchen nehmen als neuen Sportdirektor. Ich sage es ja nur.
Sein Bruder, Oliver Kahn, sein Bruder war ja auch irgendwie im Erfolg quasi, er wollte Präsident werden, ist dann gescheitert und der ist ja angetreten. Oder sein Lebensmotto ist das Kahngehen. Also der Versuch, quasi im Schatten seines Bruders da diese Erfolgsgier zu vermitteln, das ist eigentlich auch ganz spannend. Aber wir schweifen ab. Ja, wie gesagt, weil du Nachfolger angesprochen hast, Ansgar, das ist auch noch nicht geregelt oder noch nicht klar. Also heute wurde nochmal betont von KSC-Präsidenten und Beiratsvorsitzenden, dass sie sich da keinen Schnellschuss erlauben wollen. Laut Presseberichten wurden auch eine Agentur irgendwie beauftragt, um den Markt zu sondieren, die sich quasi mit der Agentur auf Sportchefs beurte quasi eingeschossen hat. Und pass auf, die Kaderplanung übernimmt jetzt quasi eine sogenannte Task Force, wo unter anderem Christian Eichmann jetzt mehr oder weniger…
Guck, jetzt haben wir den Unterschied.
Ja, er besteht auch noch aus dem Leiter des Scouting-Abteilungs, quasi Sebastian Freis und Assistenz-Trainer ist dabei, dann Michael Becker, der wirtschaftliche Geschäftsführer und abschließend. Wir haben auch einen Kaderplaner, Nechard Aigün, die quasi die laufenden Vertragsgespräche jetzt erstmal weiterführen sollen.
Und ich bin gespannt, ob Lars Dindl immer Ja oder Nein.
Ihr habt ja den ganzen Verein voller Ex-Spieler, ne?
Ja, also grundsätzlich gar nicht so sehr, aber ja, also es könnte… Ja, eigentlich nur Sebastian Freis und Christian Eichner, also jetzt in oberen Reihen.
Gut, der ist ja auch schon jetzt eine ganze Weile da, Christian Eichner. Aber dann, um wenigstens ganz kurz noch über das Sportliche zu reden. Also wir haben jetzt schon gelernt, der GSC, da lohnt ein Blick, was so neben den Kulissen passiert. Vom Sportlichen her, du hast gesagt, man ist noch nicht komplett raus, weil man hat neun Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz. Aber mit 35 Punkten und Rang 8 würde ich jetzt mal die Prognose wagen, die Saison kann man austrudeln lassen. Also all die Nebengeräusche, die es gibt, die kann man dann sportlich zumindest absorbieren, da wird nichts passieren. Was glaubst du denn, muss passieren, damit das, was der KSC sich offenbar vorgenommen hat, nämlich dass mit der Fertigstellung des Stadions so eine neue Stufe gezündet wird im Verein, dass das auch wirklich möglich ist aus sportlicher Sicht?
Ich glaube, du stellst die zentrale Frage, die sich viele aktuell auch stellen, weil tatsächlich mit der Abberufung, was die strategische Neuausrichtung bedeuten soll, wurde nicht so richtig klar. Also im Endeffekt muss man es wieder schaffen, Talente vielleicht ein bisschen länger da zu behalten oder eben halt noch ein bisschen genauer auf den Markt zu gucken und Spieler zu finden, die halt auch sich weiterentwickeln und die Mannschaft auf ein neues Niveau heben. Als gutes Beispiel sehe ich da zum Beispiel hier den Kofi Schiré, der ein Jahr von Wien nach St. Pauli ging und dann echt direkt quasi zum Premium-Trainer-Streich nach Freiburg. Also das ist ein Erfolgsmodell, dass das möglich wäre. Aber ob das halt immer so geht und ob das quasi auch der Realität entspricht, wird man sehen in Zukunft. Also das hängt ja auch ganz doll davon ab, wie viele Personen, also wer dann die handelnde Person wird gewissermaßen als Sportchef. Was ich quasi positiv sehe, ist, dass man ein gutes Gerüst hat. Also ich glaube, mit Gersbeck, Vanicek und Schleusener beispielsweise kann man gut weitermachen. Die Frage ist jetzt, ob man beispielsweise noch einen oder den anderen von den Leihspielern bekommt. Also zum Beispiel Michael Kaufmann in der Form, wie er aktuell ist, der quasi maßgeblich zum Rückrundenerfolg beiträgt. Den würde ich gerne weiter im KSC Trikot sehen. Aber ob der finanzierbar ist, steht auf einem ganz anderen Blatt. Also im Endeffekt muss der Stamm erweitert werden, ein bisschen verjüngt werden, und dass man ein bisschen wieder nach oben schielen kann. Wobei ich sagen muss, der aktuelle Platz 8 ist echt super.
Das ist schon euer altes Oben.
Da habe ich halt nichts zu meckern. Also so sage ich mal. Wenn ich so an die erfolgreichsten Mannschaften denke, das ist halt immer das, was ich am Anfang meinte. Das würde ich halt gerne wieder sehen. Also ich glaube, beim KSC ist Identifikation ganz wichtig von Spielern. Die müssen auch zum Teil aus der Region kommen, wie man so schön sagt. Spieler, die vielleicht woanders gescheitert sind, es nochmal Leuten zeigen wollen, wie man so schön sagt. Und vielleicht auch unseren Talenten, weil Talente haben wir genug. Die müsste man vielleicht nur nochmal besser, so blöd es klingt, verkaufen, wenn sie uns quasi nicht selber in die 1. Liga schießen. Ich mein, bestes Beispiel dafür tut mir bis heute weh, weil Ansgar angesprochen hat, wie jung der Muslija ist. Ich weine tatsächlich beispielsweise in dem Marvin Melem immer noch eine Träne nach. Oder zwei sogar. Gerade jetzt, wenn ich ihn spielen sehe. Und der wird jetzt auch erst 26.
Also wir sehen, der Umbruch, der sich in der Infrastruktur jetzt dann bald abgeschlossen ist, der muss im Kader jetzt erst noch kommen und dann schauen wir, wo das den KSC hinbefördert. Normalerweise ist es so, wenn man als Letzter drankommt in diesem 2. Lege Kurzpass, da ist das eine sehr unangenehme Situation. Weil es heißt, man steht in der Tabelle am schlechtesten davon ein und man muss sehr lange warten. Ich habe aber jetzt immer mehr das Gefühl bekommen, Ansgar, dass das diesmal – also fast so, als hätte ich mir das überlegt, aber war natürlich Zufall – ganz gut war, weil du so viele Chaos-Themen jetzt hier gehört hast. Da musst du dich doch mit Hannover 96 auf einem ganz entspannten 9. Platz 34 Punkte, da musst du doch richtig zufrieden sein.
Ja, seit – wann war das? Samstag, 15.20 Uhr ist, glaube ich, auch komplett der Ruhrpuls für das Ende der Saison eingekehrt, seit man die bravourösen Sandhausener an die Wand gespielt hat.
Niedergerungen.
Ich durfte ja da sein, im Stadion. Das schaffe ich ja leider aus Gründen nicht ganz so häufig, aber ich war da, ich durfte es mir antun. Und die erste Halbzeit war wirklich, wirklich grauenhaft, dass ich sehr viel Angst hatte, wenn man lag eins und hinten, man hätte deutlich höher zurückliegen können, schießt einen sehr glücklichen Ausgleich zur Pause, wenn das mit einem Rückstand da in die Pause geht, so wie da auch sich das Publikum präsentiert hat. Die Ultras sind ja aus der Nordkurve gegangen, entweder in die Kneipo oder auf die Westribüne und haben einfach sich mal ein Ruhr Bier geholt, haben die Stimme geschont. Es hatte so ein bisschen was von Corona-Atmosphäre, nur halt mit 20.000 Mann im Stadion. Das war auch mal ganz interessant. Wenn das mit einem Rückstand in die Kabine gegangen wäre, dann wäre es komplett eskaliert, glaube ich. So hat man es gerade noch so gerettet, sich an den eigenen Haaren aus dem Sumpf gezogen. Und jetzt ist die Saison eigentlich durch. Also, ich weiß nicht, ob man bei 35 Punkten auf Platz 8, wenn man da vielleicht noch ein bisschen nach unten guckt, aber jetzt bei uns ist es eigentlich relativ klar, das wird jetzt irgendwo zwischen Platz 8 und Platz 12 einlaufen. Bei Platz 8 oder 9 hätte man das offiziell vor der Saison herausgegeben, das Saisonziel komplett erreicht und ist voll im Soll. Fakt ist, so wie sich die Saison dann ab der Winterpause gestaltet hat, wollen alle nur noch einen Haken dran machen. Und da Hannover 96 ein Verein der Konstanten ist, hat sich direkt nach dem Spiel gegen Sandhausen Martin Kindt ja dann auch direkt wieder in die Presse gesetzt und ist die Transferstrategie für den Sommer schon mal verraten, wie viele, wo und was für Art Spieler man holen möchte, damit alle Sportdirektoren oder Mannschaften, die eventuell dann einen haben, Bescheid wissen, worauf man sich einstellen kann, was man so fordern kann. Ja, also ist alles wie immer im Grunde bei Hannover.
Ja, also du wirst uns gleich noch sagen dürfen, was Martin Kindt da angekündigt hat, denn wir wollen Martin Kindt natürlich beim Wort nehmen, aber erst musst du mir bitte noch erklären, was denn da passiert ist. In der Hinrundentabelle, ich meine, wir alle wissen, die Hinrunde war in sich ja auch noch mal aufgeteilt, aber da ist man auf Rang 5 eingelaufen, mit 28 Punkten, 5 Punkte Rückstand auf Rang 3. In der Rückrundentabelle Hannover 96 auf dem 16. Platz und 3 der 6 Punkte hat man jetzt eben in diesem 3 zu 1 Sieg gegen Sandhausen, der ja so zustande gekommen ist, wie du es gerade beschrieben hast, erspielen können. Was hat zu dieser Serie von, ich glaube, 9 Spielen mit 3 Unentschieden, ne, 4 Unentschieden, Entschuldigung, und 5 Niederlagen geführt?
Ja, das ist eine sehr spannende Frage, die glaube ich keiner so wirklich beantworten kann, außer ich halte die Verantwortlichen, die es aber aus offensichtlichen Gründen nicht sagen. Keine Ahnung, ob es das verregnete Trainingslager in Belek war, wo man sich mal eingefunden hat, vielleicht war im Gegensatz zu Fürth vorhin, die ja ganz froh über, ich würde sagen schon, Paderborn, ich bin abgeführt.
Das ist wirklich peinlich, ich habe heute noch nie für eine verwechselt.
Ja, also wirklich, nein, Paderborn war ja ganz froh über die Winterpause, ich glaube bei uns war das schon ein ziemlicher Nackenschlag, der da passiert ist. Wir sind ja auch relativ unbeholfen in die Saison gegangen mit dem neuen Trainer Stefan Leitel, hoch angepriesen und der wollte sein Routensystem spielen, hat dann die ersten drei Spiele teils verdient, teils unglücklich, relativ viel auf die Mütze gekriegt und hat dann nach dem Spiel gegen Regensburg auf Dreierkette umgestellt. Das hat dann sehr gut funktioniert, fast die gesamte Hinrunde lang, außer gegen die Großen, ich sag mal gegen Hamburg, gegen Heidenheim, gegen Darmstadt, ansonsten hat man eigentlich gegen alles gewonnen oder Punkte geholt. Und dann kommt die Winterpause, vermutlich haben dann alle anderen Vereine sich mal bei uns angeguckt, wie wir so spielen mit der Dreierkette, haben sich drauf eingestellt und unser Plan A, bzw. der Plan B war, hat dann nicht mehr gegriffen. Dann kommt man aus der Winterpause, kriegt das Topspiel gegen Lautern, führt zur Pause 1-0 zu Hause, vor ausverkauftem Haus und geht dann sang und klanglos unter, sieht gegen das – gut, das wusste man damals noch nicht – erfrischte St. Pauli mit auch teils dubiosen Wahrgeschichten, die kamen ja dann auch noch oben drauf, führt gegen Paderborn 2-0 nach vier Minuten, was auch keiner verstanden hat, ja, nur um dann nach fünf Minuten das 2-1 zu kassieren, um dann komplett gelähmt zu sein. Also, und dann reiht sich alles beieinander, dann spielt man superglücklich gegen Regensburg und Rostock 1-1, verliert 2-1 gegen Magdeburg, was du auch 4-0 verlieren kannst. Das sind unerklärliche Dinge, die halt ineinandergreifen, wo keiner wirklich die Lösung gefunden hat. Dann wird von flexiblen Aufstellungen gesprochen. Der Trainer hat sich angeblich auf der Pressekonferenz gesagt, noch nie vercoacht, stellt aber ständig vor, während und nach den Spielen zwischen Dreier- und Viererkette um und freut sich über seine Variabilität, die aber im Grunde nur zu sehr viel Verwirrung führt. Und wie gesagt, im Endeffekt kommt dann dabei heraus, dass der Kader, der zwar mit vielen jungen Spielern, aber auch mit sehr vielen gestandenen Spielern, die nicht für wenig Geld bei uns spielen werden, so zusammengestellt ist, dass man jetzt sagt, ach, wir machen den nächsten Umbruch.
Und dieser Umbruch wird der mit Stefan Leitl weiter vollzogen. Also ich bin jetzt nicht jemand, der sagt, immer sofort gleich die Trainer rauswerfen. Andererseits wäre es jetzt auch nicht so komplett untypisch für Hannover 96, da auch nochmal was zu verändern. Du hast ja schon gesagt, er ist mit großen Lobpreisungen gekommen aus Fürth. Wie blickst du denn jetzt ein paar Monate später auf sein Werk?
Es war ja immer gesagt, dass diese Saison eine wird, wo man erstmal ein Gerüst bauen muss. Die vergangene Saison mit Zimmermann und Dabrowski war ja eine zum komplett vergessen. Eigentlich schon seit Spieltag 2, glaube ich. Diese Saison sollte ein Gerüst aufgebaut werden mit einstelliger Tabellenplatz und wenn es geht nach oben anklopfen. Das hätte man mit einem Sieg gegen Lautern am 18. Spieltag. Da wäre man irgendwie Vierter gewesen und ganz obendran an den Relegationsring. Da hat man sich jetzt von verabschiedet. Jetzt muss man sich weiter konsolidieren und wenn man gegen Sandhausen verloren hätte, hätte trotz allen Bekundungen auf Homepage und in den Medien in Hannover, dann wäre Leitl nicht mehr da gewesen. Also der hat schon eine sehr große Chance bekommen nach Braunschweig, nach dem verlorenen Derby, in der Länderspielpause, da mit den Jungs zu arbeiten und da irgendwie ein bisschen Struktur wieder reinzubekommen. Das hat so halb funktioniert. Aber der nächste Umbruch im Sommer wird dann auch mit Stefan Leitl passieren. Vor allem, auch bei allem, was gesagt wurde, trotz dieser desaströsen Rückrunde, bislang wusste ja auch keiner, wer es sonst machen soll. Natürlich wäre dann wieder Daniel Stendl da gewesen. Der ist damals bei dem Abstieg 2.16 mit Thomas Schaaf damals noch bei uns. Er ist als U19-Trainer eingesprungen und hat dann den Weg bereitet für den Aufstieg 2.17. Ja, so rum müsste es gewesen sein. Mittlerweile ist er wieder zurück bei uns als U23-Trainer, wäre aber wieder auch keine nachhaltige Lösung geworden. So toll ist der Trainermarkt in der 2. Liga auch nicht. Da haben wir auch schon ein bisschen was ausprobiert, dass man jetzt tatsächlich sagt, wir probieren es jetzt wirklich mit dem Personalmann und Leitel, weil was Besseres finden wir nicht auf dem Markt.
Okay, und jetzt hat Martin Kind, wusste gar nicht, dass der bei Hannover 96 was zu sagen hat, der hat die Transferstrategie verraten. Was konnte man denn da erfahren?
Ja, also natürlich ist die Planung bei uns immer schon immer schon lang und groß und immer super geplant, aber bei uns ist es halt immer die Eigenheit, dass wenn es einen guten Zeitpunkt gibt, Martin Kind dann angerufen wird und sagt, wie wir es machen wollen, nämlich wir bauen in allen Mannschaftsteilen mal wieder um, also Abwehr, Mittelfeld, Sturm. Gerade Stürmer ist bei uns so eine Geschichte ganz vorne drin, wo es tatsächlich fehlt. Auch im Mittelfeld haben sich sehr viele Lücken gezeigt, Außenverteidiger-Positionen, also er hat schon recht damit. Es ist ja mal die Frage, ob man es dann auch mit Zitate in die Presse schreibt. Er möchte gerne auf zwei Säulen arbeiten. Junge, frische Spieler wie Foti und Tresoldi, das Originalzitat. Dazu sei gesagt, dass Foti von Eintracht Frankfurt geliehen ist bis 2024 und dann definitiv dahin zurückgehen wird. Tresoldi ist unser Juwel im Sturm mit 18 Jahren, der aber auch noch keinen Tor im Profibereich geschossen hat. Zum anderen Qualitätsspieler, die aber größtenteils noch verpflichtet werden müssen, mit einer Altersgrenze für Neuzugänge bei 25. Aber bei den Ausnahmefällen gibt es natürlich auch immer, aber da geht es dann auch über 30. Fünf bis sechs neue Spieler, neun Leute, die abgehen könnten, von denen man maximal zwei halten will, stand jetzt. Also es ist alles, steht alles da. Also im Grunde braucht man nur neue Presse plus Abo als Sportdirektor der zweiten Bundesliga und weiß im Grunde schon Bescheid.
Macht es auch ein bisschen einfacher in Verhandlungen, wenn man auch weiß, Hannover 96 braucht jetzt hier, weil wir haben hier jemanden, der wird erst 26, wenn die Transferperiode schon angebrochen ist. Und deswegen, naja.
Oder du begründest es halt gut. Mit den Ausnahmefällen geht es ja auch über 30. Das ist schön zu wissen. Nachdem jetzt Therode gesagt hat, er macht bei Schalke nicht mehr, war er natürlich bei Hannover direkt. Eigentlich können wir es uns nicht leisten, aber schon.
Aber das fand ich ganz interessant zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt eben gerade schon bei Therode sind. Ich dachte eigentlich, dass Nielsen und auch Teuchert durchaus, dass es eigentlich schon ein Sturmdu sein könnte, was funktionieren könnte. Aber du sagst, da gibt es Handlungsbedarf.
Ja, weil beide ja jetzt nicht so der klassische Neuner sind. Also davon hatten wir zu Beginn der Saison zwei, nämlich Weidand und Hinterseher. Hinterseher haben wir dann noch irgendwie nach Rostock verkauft bekommen, mit dem wir jetzt aber auch nicht viel anfangen können. Henrik Weidand steht bei zwei Saisontoren, davon eins gegen den KSC, was ich auch live bejubeln durfte. Schönen Gruß da nochmal an Marcel Franke, der sehr viel dazu beigetragen hat, dass dieses Tor so fallen konnte, wie es gefallen ist. Ansonsten ist Harbert Nielsen. Ja, der hat zwar sieben Tore, hat der in der Hinrunde auch gemacht, spielt aber quasi überall auf dem Platz, nur halt nicht als Neuner. Der ist mal ein Zehner, dann läuft er als Achter rum, holt sich sehr viele Bälle weit hinten und verteilt die dann weiter nach vorne. Der ist halt keiner, den du nach vorne in die Spitze stellst, ist aber einer, der extra mit Stefan Leitl mitgegangen ist. Ja, anscheinend braucht man keinen anderen, und Teuchert ist halt auch eher so der hängende Spieler, auch keiner, den man im Strafraum bedient. Der hat jetzt seine 10 Tore gemacht, das ist super, ist aber trotzdem nicht kritikfrei bei den Fans, was halt auch wieder eine ganz eigene Geschichte ist, weil dem dann immer vorgeworfen wird, ja, aber er ist immer so lustlos und geht nicht mit ins Gegenpressing, hat halt seine 10 Tore geschossen in der Saison und ohne ihn wäre es noch viel wilder, aber da ist dann auch mal der Anspruch der Fans dann noch ein ganz anderer, wer denn eigentlich hier die Tore schießen müsste, es dann aber trotzdem hier nie tut, sondern immer nur woanders.
Apropos Anspruch der Fans, wenn ich einen anderen Podcast höre, der eventuell in einer WG stattfindet und von www.meinsportpodcast.de veröffentlicht wird, da spricht ein uns beiden bekannter Hannover 96-Fans immer von den Derby-Versagern, wenn es um 96 geht. Und das ist ja tatsächlich zu dieser – also, dass das eine Umbruchssaison würde, das war schon vorher angekündigt. Dann hatte man kurz die Hoffnung, zu träumen. Diese Hoffnung war dann relativ schnell dahin und dann kam die Angst. Und jetzt aber trudelt das Ganze so aus. Das heißt im Grunde, du hast es ja vorhin auch schon so angedeutet, es könnte sein, dass wir uns nach 34 Spieltagen umdrehen, zurückblicken auf diese Saison und sagen, na im Ende haben wir, es war zwar ein bisschen dramatischer als es hätte sein müssen, aber wir haben eigentlich bekommen, was wir uns versprochen haben. Mein Gefühl ist aber, dass dieses 1 zu 1 im Hinspiel gegen Braunschweig und jetzt dieses 0 zu 1 vor allem jetzt dann ja vor gar nicht so lange Zeit am 19. März in Braunschweig, dass das für die Fans diese Saison so fast ein bisschen überschattet.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Gerade es gibt jedes Jahr, wenn beide Mannschaften in einer Liga spielen, gibt es immer die Frage, willst du lieber aufsteigen oder lieber ein Derbysieg? Und dann gibt es immer, je nachdem, wie realistisch der Aufstieg ist, eigentlich immer eine Mehrheit für ein Derbysieg. Dieses Derby in der Hinrunde kam genau nach vier Spielen in Folge, die man teils sehr souverän gewonnen hat und man sich da schon nicht besonders stark gezeigt hat. Man lag da auch hinten, hat dann noch ein Ausgleich gerettet für heimischer Kulisse. Und das war im Grunde nicht mit dem zu vergleichen, was man die Spiele davor und danach auf dem Platz gezeigt hat. Und gerade in Anbetracht dieser Rückrunde, wo sich jede Woche für den tollen Support auswärts und zu Hause bedankt wurde und wöchentlich der Satz fiel, jetzt müssen wir den Fans aber auch mal was zurückgeben, kam es dann halt zu diesem Derby, wo eine unfassbare Lustlosigkeit auf dem Platz gezeigt wurde. Und das ist quasi in der Nachspielzeit der zweiten Halbzeit, dass es 0-1 gab. Ja, das war, glaube ich, bei einer Schussbilanz von 27 zu 3 oder was das war, auch eigentlich nur Braunschweig zu verdanken, dass es nicht schon früher und deutlicher und höher so ausgefallen war. Und ich glaube, das Allerschlimmste wäre fast noch gewesen, wenn man da mit einem 0-0 nach Hause gegangen wäre und sich da fast noch zufrieden hingestellt hätte nach dem Motto, ja, aber wir sind ja weiter Derbysieger von vor drei Jahren und alles nicht so schlimm. Und jetzt dann gegen Sandhausen aber wirklich. Und so haben sie mal richtig die komplette Breitseite abbekommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Versager, wie gesagt, die aktive Fanszene hat mit seinem einmaligen Stimmungsboykott die ganze Sache jetzt für sich bewertet. Und ja, aber im Endeffekt hast du, wenn du auf die Saison zurückguckst, nichts, wo du sagen kannst, oh, das war jetzt aber toll. Natürlich Hinrunde, viermal in Folge gewonnen.
Also, das Derby-Versager, sagt der Tobi natürlich auch immer nur ironisch. Wir wollen hier ja im Rasenfunk jetzt auch nicht irgendwelche Menschen zu Versagern machen wegen sportlicher Leistung. Aber wie ist denn generell dann die Stimmung im Umfeld? Also, das mit dem Derby ist jetzt noch mal ein Sonderfall. Da haben wir jetzt den Stimmungsboykott gehabt. Gleichzeitig haben wir ja aber auch den Sonderfall Martin Kind und all das auf und ab, das ist da jetzt in den letzten Jahren gab. Wie ist da der aktuelle Status bei Hannover?
Ja, er ist weiter kompliziert, der Status, wie man als Kind der 90er und Internetaffiner Mensch der Nullerjahre so sagt. Naja, der Stand ist, dass es keinen neuen Stand gibt. Wie gesagt, wir haben ja unser beliebtes 2 plus 2 Gremium laut 50 plus 1 Regelung und DFL ganz legal, dass das so ist, dass man so entscheiden kann. Und der EV hatte gedacht, er hätte Argumente, dieses Gremium zu umgehen. Die Gerichte haben gesagt, so wie ihr das gemacht habt, funktioniert das nicht. Und seitdem herrscht Funkstille. Glaube ich, man redet mittlerweile wohl wieder über Dritte miteinander, auch weil Martin Kind jetzt stramm auf die 80 zugeht und irgendwann doch mal ein Nachfolger für ihn gefunden werden muss, der natürlich von beiden Seiten abgesegnet werden muss. Wie da die Ideen sind, ist vollkommen offen. Mal schauen, auch wie sich die EV-Fan-nahe Seite bei der nächsten Mitgliederversammlung dazu positionieren wird, um, die ja angetreten war mit dem Ziel, Martin Kind das Kapitel zu beenden. Man hat es probiert, es hat nicht funktioniert. Mal sehen, wie die Fans das dann gutieren werden. Und ansonsten bleibt es weiterhin einfach ein Thema, was für weiter viel gute Laune und Überschriften sorgen wird. Also deswegen gibt es bei uns dann auch den Boulevard-Reporter vor Ort sogar zwei oder drei. Also die haben immer was zu schreiben. Und wenn es das Arbeitsgericht ist, was besucht wird.
Man muss da nur über Jahre hinweg… Ja, das glaube ich. Aber was ist denn dann so dein persönliches Gefühl, was jetzt dann die nächste, die nähere Zukunft von Hannover 96 aussieht? Ich will dir jetzt gar nicht die 5-Jahresfrage stellen, weil das ist glaube ich ein bisschen albern, weil man bei 96 nie so genau weiß, was passiert. Aber dann wirtschaftlich sieht das ja eigentlich alles ganz ordentlich aus. Also im Vergleich zu den beiden anderen Vereinen, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben, Hannover hatte immer so ein Rohrergebnis in den letzten zwei dokumentierten Spielzeiten rund um 50 Millionen Euro. Schonmal das Doppelte, als das so grob, was Paderborn und der KSC haben. Der Personalauffang ist auch höher, hast du ja vorhin auch schon gesagt. Man kann ganz gute Gehälter zahlen. Das heißt, allein von den Zahlen her und ja auch von der Infrastruktur und durchaus ja auch von der Historie ist ja Hannover 96 ein Verein, der eigentlich in den Top 25 mitspielt und da müsste eben dann auch immer wieder mal ein Aufstiegsrennen mit dabei sein. Siehst du das in näherer Zukunft kommen?
Also es ist ja angekündigt, also die Kombination Mann-Leitel ist angetreten, mit in drei Jahren aufzusteigen. Davon ist jetzt Jahr eins fast um. Also die grobe Planung ist 2025. Neulich hat Martin Kind noch mal 2026 gesagt, also da dann alle, alle spätestens möchte Hannover 96 in der ersten Liga sein. Und dafür werden jetzt die Grundlagen gelegt. Und ich kann jetzt anhand dieser Saison doch nicht absehen, dass sich das so verfestigt, dass man in anderthalb Jahren soweit ist, dass man groß im Aufstiegsrennen mit dabei ist. Andererseits ist die 2. Liga im Durchschnitt qualitativ jetzt auch nicht so prall. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt diese Rückrundenserie, du hast sie angesprochen, ich habe sie auch mehrfach erwähnt, und wir sind halt trotzdem noch auf einem einstelligen Tabellenplatz, was ja auch zeigt, wie viel da unter uns noch spielt, was auch nicht in der Lage ist, mehr Punkte als wir zu generieren. Und von daher wird es in einem Verein wie Hannover, wenn man nicht so eine komplett absurde Saison wie die vorherige spielt, eigentlich immer gelingen, in der oberen Tabellenhefte mit dabei zu sein. Allein schon aus den Gründen, Geld, Mittel, allein schon, dass wir das 49.000er-Stadion haben, was wir diese Saison mehrfach ausverkauft bekommen haben. Wenn man sieht, wer aus der ersten Liga aller Voraussicht nach runterkommen wird, werden auch da Zahlungskräftige und Mannschaften mit hohem Fanaufkommen da sein, um auch das wieder nächste Saison voll zu machen. Also wir kriegen darüber auch wichtiges Geld, was wir brauchen. Andererseits, wenn du sagst, wir haben doppelt so viel Geld zur Verfügung, sind wir aber nicht doppelt so gut wie die beiden angesprochenen Vereine, mit denen ich hier so gerade beisammen bin, mit Karlsruhe und Paderborn. Von daher wird schon natürlich immer kritisch und da fragt, wo stehen wir, wo wollen wir hin? Martin Kind will nach oben. Der hat Markus Mann damals, 2019, schon bei Eser Brücken als Sportdirektor begutachtet, hat gesagt, das wird irgendwann mal mein Mann, pun intended, bei jeder Überschrift in Hannover. Und deswegen hat er ihn dann irgendwann aus Hoffenheim, was heißt irgendwann, 21, aus der Akademie in Hoffenheim geholt, als er dann da gelandet war, als wir einen brauchten. Mittlerweile haben wir auch, glaube ich, nur noch einen einzigen Sportdirektor unter Vertrag, also wir hatten ja mal Zeiten, da waren es zwei oder drei. Und ich schätze, Markus Mann, also der wird in der Fernszene sehr, sehr, sehr positiv gesehen, auch wenn sich einige seiner Transfers auch nicht als die Eier legenden Wollmichsäue entpuppt haben, für die sie gehandelt wurden bei der Verkündung der Transfers. Trotzdem halte ich ihn für einen fähigen Sportdirektor, der das hinbekommen kann. Was aber dann auch immer daran liegt, ob das Umfeld, inklusive Geschäftsführer, auch so ruhig bleiben kann, wenn es dann mal soweit ist.
Das werden wir dann verfolgen, wenn es denn soweit ist. Ansgar, ich danke dir und ich danke euch dreien. Das ist ein bisschen ausgeufert. Ich danke euch sehr, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Ich meine, ihr wart eingeladen im Rasenfunk. Es wird euch jetzt nicht so komplett aus dem Nichts erwischt haben, aber es ist jetzt schon sehr spät. Deswegen danke ich euch dreien sehr herzlich. Ich freue mich, dass Kevin Bublitz mal wieder hier war. Als Add Kevin Bublitz könnt ihr ihm auch auf Twitter folgen. Hört den Padercast. Danke dir, Kevin, dass du mal wieder die Zeit hattest für den Rasenfunk.
Bisher habt ihr noch nie ein Ligaspiel gegen uns gewonnen. Wenn das gelingt, dann werdet ihr wieder aufsteigen.
Das ist tatsächlich eine erstaunliche Statistik. Ich weiß nicht, wie oft der KST schon gegen den SC Paderborn gewonnen hat. Das kannst du jetzt nachgucken. Während ich, Jörn Kreuzer, danke. Ganz herzlichen Dank, lieber Jörn, dass du mal hier mit dabei warst. Jetzt auch aktiv im Rasenfunk und nicht immer als Hörer. Danke dir, Jörn, für deine Zeit.
Bitte, ich habe zu danken. Herzlichen Dank für die Einladung. Ich hoffe, ich konnte das ein bisschen ordnen. Naja, wir werden sehen, wie es weitergeht.
Wir werden sicherlich viel Feedback auf mitmachen.rasenfunk.de dafür bekommen. Ich habe auf jeden Fall jetzt das Gefühl, mehr zu wissen, als vorher. Unter anderem kann ich jetzt so ganz grob die KSC und Hannover 96, nein, und Paderborn-Stürme auseinanderhalten. Meine Güte, es ist aber auch schwierig bei drei Vereinen. Danke ebenfalls auch an Ansgar Löcke, der Ed Ansgar unterstrich L. Danke dir, Ansgar, dass du mal wieder hier im Rasenfunk warst. Sehr gerne. Ihr lieben Leute, ihr merkt, ich brauche dringend Feierabend, vielleicht auch Urlaub. Den wird es nicht geben, denn es geht weiter. Am Ostermontag erscheint die Schlusskonferenznummer, ich glaube sogar die 404. Mal gucken, ob mir dazu ein Witz einfällt. Die wird allerdings erst am Ostermontag Nachmittag erscheinen. Und Stand jetzt habe ich erst 50 Prozent der Gäste gefunden. Es ist einfach in jeder Woche etwas los im Rasenfunk. Unterstützt uns bitte auf Rasenfunk.de. Erfahrt ihr, wie und an die wenigen, die uns noch über FIDOR unterstützen. Das müsst ihr jetzt unbedingt ändern, denn FIDOR wird den Geschäftsbetrieb einstellen. Also dieses Konto gibt es einfach nicht mehr. Das wussten wir ehrlich gesagt auch schon im letzten Herbst. Auch deshalb GmbH, neue Bank, neues Konto und so weiter. Jetzt müsst ihr wirklich umstehen, ansonsten kommt bald nichts mehr bei uns an. Ihr Lieben, danke fürs Zuhören, danke euch dreien fürs Mitmachen und dann bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, ciao!